Hello and welcome to today's episode.
This is Rawkode live. I am Rawkode slash
David McKay and I am very pleased today
to introduce a whole host of people as
we can see here. We have six,
five sorry, six including myself, guest today and
I'm gonna delegate the introductions because it's too
many new names for me and I'm not
very clever. So
I'll introduce Paul, Paul Burt from OpenEBS,
Maya Data. Please take it away. Yeah. Howdy.
Thanks for having us.
We we're deeply invested in open source, so
we figured we'd bring the open source community
with us. It's kind of the plan here.
So I'm the director of
community and marketing at Myadata. We build OpenEBS
and Litmus Chaos are kind of our
top tier open source projects that you may
recognize. I think we're gonna explore Maya Store,
which is a new kinda
fangled component of OpenEBS that does some really
cool stuff with technology from Intel and
Linux foundation projects and other stuff. So we
have Kiran Mova, who is one of the
cofounders of Maya data along with us, and
he's the architect of OpenEBS.
We have Jeffrey,
who is our CTO at My Data and
works deeply on the
MyAstore project.
And then Glenn Boolingham and Jan, I think,
are product management and architects,
software developers
correspondingly.
So we've got a a full house here
today.
Yeah. We're setting a record for the most
guests I've had on the stream at any
one time. That's awesome.
Now
we're I believe we're we're gonna start with
a few slides just to talk around what
OpenEBS
is. So,
Kevin, I believe you're gonna share your screen.
Yes.
Thanks, Paul and David, for having us
here today.
Let me see if I can figure out
share the screen here. I haven't prepared slides
specifically for this event, but I do have
some slides that I want to share from
the last
presentation that we had at KubeCon.
It'll be a trimmed down version of it
before we get into the most interesting stuff
on my store
just to set up a context on the
origins of OpenEBS
and how we came down to working on
My Store.
So this was slightly,
you know,
older survey now. It's from 02/2019, '2 thousand
'20 is going to be published
at the upcoming North America KubeCon. But OpenEBS
is one of the most evaluated storages
in the open source for straightforward workloads on
Kubernetes.
And we call the storage pattern that we
have implemented as container attached storage.
And we while we are the leading open
source
platform
or container attached storage example, there are, like,
some commercial options available as well.
You know, like Portworx, which was recently in
the news, is the one that I was
also featured in the survey.
So the origins are pretty simple. Like, I
think we think that congress law is
kind of getting realized right now at all
industries.
In some recent article that I've read, there
are no more
company I mean, no data data companies kind
of survive now, and every company is a
data company, whether it's Bloomberg or
could be Ben's or every organization
has become like a data organization
as well.
This is a story from CNCF end user
report which talks
which kind of represents the way teams are
organized at Bloomberg
and how Congress law can get applied there
with respect to disaggregated teams,
small number of teams working on several thousands
of microservices,
and a much, much smaller team
supporting
what do you call a platform, a SRE
team supporting them. And this is possible with
Kubernetes
and other CNCF technologies
that enable these teams to automate their entire
infrastructure as a service within their organizations.
So
the Kubernetes started off as an orchestrator for
state level upload, it's kind of soon transformed
or it's enabling
data to be done in Kubernetes as well.
And we also see the shift coming from
the way databases are architected as the teams
are transforming from
specialized
or,
you know, layered teams to more functional teams.
Even the types of databases
that are getting deployed within these are different.
It's not a single database that all the
data goes to, but rather depending on the
service that you are providing,
your databases are optimized for that.
We tend to see now
variety of databases in an organization's
stack.
So a few other reasons,
especially with respect to agility that's driving the
teams to go into microservices and disaggregate it
is also this notion of data gravity. Once
we
end up using some existing
technology or, a data layer,
even though we kind of
are becoming better with agility in terms of
application development and the choice of databases. But
the real data gets stored onto some platforms,
and you kind of get locked into that
one. And this can actually slow down the
growth. This is one of the reasons why
we thought
we should not get locked into
any kind of storage when you're running your
applications.
And we'll try to see how we try
to provide you this data,
like, vendor agnostic way of setting up your
data infrastructure.
And
the other thing
is about the new
hardware that's available and new technologies or, like,
new techniques that are available to make optimal
use of this new hardware. For example, this
shows a 96 core machine with almost close
to one terabyte RAM that's available on the
node.
And none of the
existing technologies can fully optimize the power of
such boxes. Right? It's almost like, you know,
even the
I when you're talking about processing the IO,
how do you go from
working at, like
that are that are optimized for working at
four core of, like, eight core CPUs to
96 core CPUs. Right?
Things around the storage also have been changing.
A lot of stacks around the storage infrastructures
have been rewritten.
In fact, like,
by using the IO reading or lockless mode
techniques.
What we are trying to see is, okay,
now we have NVMe protocol that can work
at a much faster speed than the traditional
protocols.
Can we make use of the newer hardware
and the
transport protocols that are faster and enable you
to process more IOs to deliver you a
high performance storage?
Another interesting aspect was
about the shift towards user space to
provide you with a better
software delivery experience while
not compromising on the
performance itself.
User space tends to make us believe that,
okay, we are going to lose out on
some performance. But I think what we want
to show via the master project
that
and master isn't the first one that we
attempted. We tried
to do this with couple of other projects
and before coming up with,
you know, putting all those learnings from the
previous projects. Most of us on the call
today come from CFS background
that was focused on
maintaining the data consistency, but at the expense
of, like, performance. We try to get those
learnings to build milestone that's both
developed on open standards, providing you the performance,
and optimizing the
infrastructure that you have.
So rewrite was inevitable,
and
we will try to walk through My Store,
which is our latest engine, see how some
of these aspects that we developed really
came to life with that.
Just in terms of few more slides or,
like, you know, these are the early adopters
on the catalog that we have for the
OpenEBS project.
It's actually the list is quite big now
with 25
more public references.
And we also have, like, many
more more customers and partners talking about OpenEBS
as the or the container attached storage as
a way to deploy your applications. And
we actually support both local PVs, make it
easy to run local PVs as well as
support a replicated storage. Right?
The reason for doing that, the cognitive workloads
tend to have
the distribution logic built into them.
Many times, when they're getting started, they just
want a local storage which is operating at
the speed of the disk. So
for these, we make it easy to run,
you know, consume
the storage that's available on the notes and
carve it out and provide it to the
applications
without adding, like, data services, like, snapshot capabilities
or, like, you know,
few other things like, you know, optimized backups
or incremental backups, that kind of stuff. But
as we have noticed, as people start using
this, they get really comfortable. But once they
run the
applications for a longer period, they tend to
ask for other capabilities as well,
you know, like snapshots, backup restore, and encryption.
Those things are what are getting built into
our replicated stack via My Store, which operates
at
the speed that local TVs can
provide you along with
providing the additional data service capabilities.
With that, I will hand it back to
David and
Jeffrey
in case they want to add something more
to this,
and then we'll walk into the live demo
session.
Yeah. I I guess thanks, Kiran, for the
the quick introduction. I I guess the only
thing I want to add to it is
that, the idea with with Maya storage is
that we wanted to,
rearchitect
a storage stack,
in user space because it runs in containers.
And so you need the implicit ability to
be able to decouple yourself from the kernel
because all kernels are not the same,
throughout,
the cloud providers.
And, the focus there was, to to embrace
the new technologies like NVMe NVMe over fabric.
And the only real way to to squeeze
out these performance numbers is to,
use
these lockless models. And that's not because it's
it's it's cool. It's actually very hard. It's
it's very, hard. Asynchronous
programming is a nightmare, really, no matter what
language you use really. But the the the
the interesting thing that has happened recently,
not that recently, but, you know, relatively recently,
is that storage
is now much faster than the CPUs. And
that in history has never ever been the
case. And so it requires some rethinking, and
that's what what Kiran alluded to with the
hardware changes and,
audio u ring, which is a new interface
to the Linux kernel, for example,
that has a different way of of submitting
work to the to the kernel. And that
is because the hardware is much, much faster
these days. But in order to make use
of, IO u ring, for example, it's not
like, oh, I install IO U Ring and
off I go. It's like, no. No. No.
You really have to rewrite your application,
unfortunately.
Right? So all these things together,
cloud native design,
rewriting the software, languages with concurrency primitives built
in with with Go with GoFunk instead of
pthread create, you know, these type of things.
It's a very, exciting time, I think, and
gave us the,
for us, it provided justification
to to, you know, at the very least,
give this a,
you know, a shot. So,
Maya story is is
so, you know, it's still early, but we've
we've we've put a significant amount of work
in it already.
And, yeah. So that's that's roughly it. I
hope that makes sense. Yeah.
I have some color. I feel like a
fifth grader who did, like, a book report
last week and I get to present it
now. Something that, like, has has helped this
all make sense to me is thinking in
terms of, you know, what Kieran was saying,
direct attached storage is kind of the easy
thing you reach for, but it lacks features.
And eventually,
in certain projects, you may get to a
point where you want network attached storage. You
want
features like encryption and all the fancy sorry.
I've got a angry, hungry cat in the
background.
That's misfits for you.
So you you
you're looking ultimately for getting started simply, but
growing into something that's a little more professional
or a little more feature full down the
line. And OpenEBS has been designed such that
we can support multiple storage solutions.
So we have a ZFS based solution. We
have a long horn based solution. And what
we're exploring today is Maya store, which is
based on kinda like groundbreaking technology.
So their projects like DPDK and SPDK.
Are you familiar with those, David? I I
I'm cheating actually. I asked you this before
the call. Yeah. I am definitely not familiar
with them.
Can you
well, let's expand the acronyms first. What what
do those mean?
Alright. So,
good question.
So DPDK stands for data plane development kit,
and and the emphasis here is on development
kit. So it's not a turnkey solution that
you just, you know, pull in and off
you go. Everything is is is, hunky dory
and is oriented towards networking. And the genesis
there is that,
is based on the fact that as you
get more bandwidth towards your computer system, like
hundred gig, 400 gig, or what have you,
you typically have an interrupt driven approach. So
a packet comes in, the interrupt happens, the
CPU stops, processes the interrupt, and then goes
on its merry way. But as the
rate of packets increases,
what you see is that the dominant behavior
of the CPU or the operating system rather
is getting interrupted all the time. Right? So
it doesn't make any forward progress because it's
constantly getting interrupted.
So one way to get around that is
is and what you see is that you
get interrupts that are white hot. So it
constantly gets interrupted. One way to to get
around that is to batch things. So you
get an interrupt. It's like, okay. I'm not
doing anything. Not doing anything. Not doing anything.
And then boom. You handle multiple requests in
one interrupt effectively.
The downside of that is that your bandwidth
goes up, your latency increases. Right? So that's
not ideal.
So the the idea of of of DPDK
and projects that are built on top of
it, for example, a VPP vector packet processing
from Cisco was that, well, instead of having
the kernel do all that hard work, why
not isolate a CPU one, two, or three,
or maybe four, who knows whom how much
you need. Because these days, we have,
course to spare. Right? I mean, the new
Threadripper is, like, 64 course, and it's it's
a consumer product. It's, like, an insane amount.
So instead of having the kernel do that,
what if you do that in user space
and
isolate one or two, three course
to do just the networking?
And the benefit of that is the CPU
doesn't do anything else than that. And so
the caches, the level one, two, three caches
of that CPU
remain
hot, if you will.
And, combine that with some additional technologies like
huge pages and whatnot,
you can actually see that it it it
it not only in certain situations outperforms
the kernel, but turns out to be far
more efficient because the kernel can now, you
know, worry about processes,
and and and things like that instead of
just constantly,
doing the interrupt. So that's that's CPDK.
On top of that,
they Intel also has SPDK,
which is DPDK plus
some storage specific protocols like NVMe and iSCSI,
Virtio as well. And,
but as mentioned, they are development kits, not
turnkey solutions. So so what we've done is
we we we took those,
development kits to so to speak, and and,
you we are using those,
in Maya store to
benefit from the work that they already have
done because it's it's a significant amount of
work, it is micro optimization
to it's like I've never seen that much
optimizations
before where they pat things on cache lines
and, you know, it's it's like insane, really.
And Intel has very specific software called called
VTune to do that. So I I I
can't really do that. But suffice to say,
it's highly optimized for a very, very specific
task.
And, that's what these, development kits, stand for,
if that makes sense.
Yeah. I mean, I understood at least
some of the words. Oh, there you go.
But the short version for,
someone like me who doesn't have the the
deep kinda expertise of the rest of the
panel here is you end up paying a
tax when you're using a Linux kernel. It's
been in development since 1991.
So it's kinda got this tried and true
figured out model that requires locking and doing
all these kinda slow processes
where you'll pay, like, a 30% tax just
by having the Linux kernel manage things for
you.
There's probably even deeper taxes that you pay,
having things sort of filter through the machine
that is the kernel.
And what these technologies are doing is they're
connecting your program and user space,
short circuiting the kernel, going directly to the
hardware, connecting you to the hardware.
And it's DPDK is a solution supported by
the Linux Foundation.
SPDK,
as Jeffrey mentioned, is supported by Intel.
So, there are big names investing in all
these technologies,
and a lot of effort going into making
these things really shine. And,
what we're seeing is they really do shine.
If if you've got a need for speed,
these do some really cool stuff for you.
Yeah. There there are other examples.
For example, Skyla DB,
which is a reimplementation
to a certain extent of Cassandra,
where they leverage that
same
framework to do some of the things that
they're doing like
network IO and things like that. And I
also would like to to emphasize that it's
not a
deficiency of the kernel for it not being
able to to keep up, if you will.
But it's more like
it needs to do so so many things.
It's like, you know, give it a break.
Right? And and that's basically what it boils
down to.
And, so it's it's not
not to say that, you know, the the
kernel is is is is bad. Not at
all, in fact.
It's just like yeah. I mean, there's there's
there's this thing called physics and, you know,
you can't beat that. And there is this
notion of of serialization that needs to happen
in certain cases. And and therefore, is turns
out to be somewhat more efficient to do
it that way if low latency and high
performance is your primary objective.
And when you're dealing with these low latency
devices or high bandwidth devices, however you wanna
call it, then that indeed,
is what you need.
So yeah.
Okay. Cool.
That's all really really useful. I'm gonna try
my best now to take all of that
information that we've just covered for the first
kind of fifteen minutes and just surmise that
as best as I can and then I
promise we will go straight on to the
to the actual hands on portion of this.
And I've already realized which is really good
as you saw we're talking there that I've
made my first mistake in the preparation. So
that's gonna be interesting. But we we'll call
it a knowledge transfer to the audience.
And I forgot to enable huge pages but
we can do that live. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sure. Yeah. We do
it all the time.
Yeah. Okay. So in summary and Paul you're
gonna keep me right here. Right? So.
Yeah, for sure. Stateful so Stateful services on
Kubernetes is hard because we have ephemeral compute
and containers that has to move around. So
we need to see a size specification and
open APS as an implementation of CSI, which
is ability to provide storage to workloads on
our Kubernetes cluster.
Now there seems to be multiple storage engines
with OpenEBS.
There's a C store which is the one
which is tried and tested and then Maya
store which is the one which is currently
in development,
but has some pretty wicked performance gains based
on the development kits that we were talking
about just there. Which I believe are written
in Rust which just adds an extra cool
factor or if I made that up.
Yeah. Oh, no. You're right. Yeah. It's it's
cool tech done cool. We've got all the
latest tech kinda packed in. Yeah. Yeah. We
yeah. We basically took the the the most
cool keywords and sorted them and just collect
them together and yeah.
No. But indeed, it's it's it's it's written
in Rust and for various reasons. But one
one of which is based on the experience
I've had with with other storage systems. And
99%
of the time, the issue was a more
pointer dereference or using
something that's not there anymore.
And Rust is supposed to help you
catch these things earlier.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah. So the ownership semantics,
if it compiles, won't crash. Those are all
really good benefits I would imagine for a
storage layer. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So we've got our CSI implementation. We've got
our multiple back end stores.
I mean, question in my head right now
is are are we gonna we're using my
store today and we're gonna show that off.
Is is that in a position where people
should begin to adopt it in production or
is this very much wait and see kind
of thing?
So
good question. And and and the thing is
there are certain factors that come into play.
So the,
we talked about NVMe, and we also mentioned
NVMe over fabric. If if not, then it's
basically NVMe over a network, whatever that network
is. Could be RDMA,
fiber, or TCP IP.
And one of the issues,
that is still there is that NVMe over
TCP
was only ratified last November. So it is
relatively young.
IOU ring, which is something we use, same
thing. It's relatively young. So we we are
on the border of
it's out there, but nobody's really using it.
Right? So it needs to needs to as
Kieran always says, it needs to cook. Right?
We need to cook it.
And it requires more cooking.
But,
we are working on it, with a with
a with a team on a daily basis
and trying to make it, more robust,
every day. But it still requires
some, you know, some love and attention, let's
say. But we're we're we're getting there rather
fast,
I would say. Yeah. It's ready for your
proof of concept. Let's put it that way.
Yeah. Yeah.
Alright. Well, I mean, I'm gonna put it
in production anyway. So I'll let you know
how to get on. Okay.
So let's finish this the the summary here.
The multiple back end stores can run-in two
different variations. One of them being local PV
mode and one being replicated PV mode. Does
that apply to all of the backing stores
or
just Maya store?
So I I think
per kinda what Jeffrey was tuning in on
on where
it doesn't work over NVMe over TCP IP
is relatively young.
I I think currently local PV is the
only supported mode for,
MyStor. Is that right?
Well, so so it becomes a
little bit complicated,
I suppose, to to to
express without my hands to begin with. But
so so so what we do is so
let's say you have a Kubernetes node and
that has local storage. Right?
The first thing that we do is that
we can, don't have to, and that's where
the
complexity comes. But let's assume we always do
for the sake of argument. We take that
local storage, whatever it is, slow or fast,
doesn't matter.
That we are designed to be fast doesn't
mean that we can't operate in slow mode.
We'll do that just fine.
We take that local storage and we can
create
what we call logical
volumes on that storage device such that you
can create multiple PVCs and Kubernetes speak on
on that device.
Right? So so we we we we wire
that up to, so to speak. And the
way that we connect to that local storage,
so let's say it's a local
NVMe device,
there are several ways that we can connect
to that. One is directly through the PCIe
subsystem and user space IO. We'll we'll forget
about that for now.
Or
U ring, as we talked about, IO U
ring, or AIO, which is the asynchronous interface
in Linux that has been there since I
don't know how long.
Once we've done that, that's what we call
a pool. From that pool, we can create,
replicas, as we say. And the replicas can
be or ideally are scheduled
across different nodes. Now you don't have to
do a replica, but if you want to,
you should be able to. That's the idea.
Per developer, per workload, you can determine,
if that is required.
So let's say we create a mirror, two
replicas.
These two volumes are created through our control
plane,
which
talks and understands CSI and creates CRDs in
in the control plane and whatnot, while doing
so. And these replicas are exported over NVMe
TCP,
but in user space. Right? So we we
we we don't use the kernel for that.
Then we create another NVMe controller that connects
to those two replicas
and that NVMe controller is where the workload
is,
which means that the node that wants to
write to the PVC connects to this what
we call Nexus.
It writes to the Nexus, and the Nexus
then writes to the replicas wherever they may
they may be. And that whole data path
is in NVMe
over fabric.
And so there is some some
some,
you know, nuances there in terms of, okay,
the stability because of the newness and and
whatnot.
But in principle,
that's what we usually
do. However, we can also
directly remotely connect to existing iSCSI and or
external NVMe over fabric targets. But when I
start to explain that, I lose people typically.
So I'll leave it at that.
Yeah. No. That's It sounds generally
yes. Yeah. Both are generally supported, but it
it's like a Facebook status. It's complicated
in the case of my own.
It's complicated. Yeah. I like that one. Yeah.
Yeah. And so for all intents and purposes,
you you could say it's a proxy. Right?
Proxy.
IO comes in, two IOs go go out.
Very simple. And then obviously, the rebuild and,
you know, there's some of that. But in
principle, that's what it is.
Alright. Okay. So final part of the summary
then. Hopefully, I've not missed anything.
What is recommended or I guess encouraged would
be if you're running a cloud native data
store that handles its own replication replication to
use local PV mode and avoid that nine
x storage costs, but if you're running more
traditional databases that don't have replication by default,
then it may be better to use that
replicated
volume
semantics.
And then the other thing that was mentioned
but I don't think we went into a
lot of detail is that OpenEBS provides a
lot more than that as well. Snapshotting,
backups
and other goodies too. I love the, I'll
share my screen and what it says on
the website because there's some bold claims here
so.
Kubernetes storage simplified which I just love right?
You know, this is these are hard problems
right? And I'm really glad that you and
your team here are working on the hard
bits so that I can just have the
nice easy to consume API. So that's great.
So simplifying storage is great and then I
love this one line install
so to get started so I
think that now unless there's anything you wanna
cover that I missed in the summary there,
we'll just start kicking the tires on this.
How does that sound?
Let's have at it. Let's break some stuff.
David,
just to
kinda clarify.
So if you are gonna use the existing
bit, like local p host path device,
This is the command that we proceed with.
But if you want to try on the
master,
there's a different link that we should check
out.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. We don't have to run
this helm command. I just love the fact
that it's right there direct on the page.
Like, I just love the ability for people
to get started with a one liner command.
Think as developers,
generally we don't wanna read the docs, just
wanna install and then start poking at it
and you know, that's good. Alright, so let's
cover where we are.
I try as always with this stream is
not to prepare too much in advance. So
all I've done thus far is prepare a
modest sized Kubernetes cluster. So we've got six
nodes running on Equinix metal,
each with their own.
I used basically
a heterogeneous cluster. We've got some large nodes,
some smaller nodes and some very big nodes.
So I'm have lots of RAM, some have
lots of disk and I figured we could
just talk about the trade offs that we're
making as we talk about that applied to
OpenEBS
as we go. And because we are gonna
need to configure huge pages, I've already kind
of just split my screen into six so
that we can get that out the way
first.
I've never done this before but I'm pretty
sure I can replicate my input to all
of these. I'll work that out in a
second
but can we talk about
first huge pages?
Why
do we need that for OpenEBS?
So
good question.
the the operating system
divides memory up in so called pages,
and those pages are typically four k.
And
the operating system needs to know where those
pages are loaded, who's owning them, and whatnot.
And and it keeps a small table called
oh, I I I just used this the
the short term of TLB.
I think it's transition look aside buffer or
something like that.
But suffice to say, it it keeps a
cache of which pages are loaded where.
The more memory you have, the more of
those pages you have.
The more of those pages you have, the
more likely you are to have a TLB
miss.
If you have a TLB miss, it is
a rather expensive operation.
I mean, it's it's nanoseconds.
But, you know, if you have a lot
of misses, then they amount to something. So
the idea is is, well, why don't we
use huger pages,
like two meg?
There's your answer.
So you get less
TLB misses and that means that the CPU
has to,
can focus more on the actual work than
finding the right pages to load,
effectively.
So that's, and and and and it really
adds up. That's one reason. Second reason is,
if you want to
do DMA transfer
into a PCI address from user space,
that memory location where you write from
and it's typically done with the scatter gather
list as they say. It's like call write
this collection of addresses into the PCI registers.
At the moment you say that,
you cannot have it. You you can't have
that that memory gets replaced
because
it's virtual memory. Right? So it can be
swapped out and yada yada. And if you
do DMAs, like, can't have that. You can't
all of a sudden move this piece of
memory somewhere else because by the time that
we actually DMA it, what are we DMA?
So an undocumented feature is that the huge
pages are what they what they so called
pinned into memory.
So they are put in a location,
and they stay there. They don't move.
And so those those two reasons are why,
we use,
huge pages.
Databases use them too, Right?
To reduce these these cache misses and whatnot.
Okay. That makes sense.
So how do I enable,
huge pages on the Linux kernel?
So you you you don't really have to
enable them as much rather than you need
to to tell the kernel how many you
want.
And there is a,
variable in sys,
m m or sys slash kernel m m.
I always use tab completion so I forget,
where you can basically echo in the value,
of of,
huge pages that you want. And you have
two choices. You have the
two meg pages or the one gig, and
we always use the,
two meg. And so you specify the amount
of two meg huge pages. So if you
wanna have one gig of huge page memory,
you specify five twelve. So from usability standpoint,
it's it's it's not ideal. Right? But, gets
the job done.
So I could just echo five twelve
to slash sys slash
Yeah.
So let me
open my browser. I I always forget it.
Because I I use a declarative operating system
next to a declarative
Oh, you use NextOS. Right? Yes. How do
you know that? I run NextOS too. No.
Back
for work. Yeah. But I Really?
Yeah. How interesting.
So
it is
let me grab that thing here.
Alright. We can actually spin up on
Equinix Medal. If I had known I had
an on the stream as well, I would
maybe have been as bold to drop off.
Expert
is a big word, but considering all the
others, alternatives, this was the least, worrisome, I
would say.
Let me see.
Well, it's actually in the in the in
the in the quick start. Maybe that's easier.
I've just pasted that one, Jeffrey, into private
chat, if that helps. In any regard. Oh.
Yeah.
See. Thank you. Okay. So
let me just
I know people watching this stream are not
really gonna be able to tell because of
the replication here. But we're echoing five twelve
to sys kernel huge pages huge pages blah
blah blah blah blah. Yes. Exactly.
We will Yes. Click that into the show
notes in case anyone is Yeah. Yeah. And
if you then type cat proc slash
mem info, I think it is, it
it should say, there you go, huge page
total, five twelve. Huge pages free, five twelve.
Now,
one unfortunate thing is is that when the
node runs Kubernetes,
the kubelet needs to know about these huge
pages. And unfortunately,
for one reason, that is, unknown to me,
however, is that
you need to actually restart the kubelet. The
kubelet is not
updating those values. So we have to restart
the kubelet,
and then,
you know, if you have a bad day,
then it's already game over. But
Alright.
We have restarted the kubelet.
See if I could still run get notes
on my cluster. Alright. I think we're good.
So we've enabled huge pages
and all six of our worker nodes at
least. I won't bother with the control plan.
Yeah. Right. Yep.
So
and then
yeah. Oh, sorry. You you just go right
ahead. I'll just answer as you go.
Well, I mean, normally I I try to
follow the documentation.
But I know that we're we're we're playing
with my store today.
Maybe not gonna be following what is recommended
in the documentations, or is that a incorrect
assumption? Yeah. So we have a documentation for
my store as well. If you just go
to the
alpha features,
is right there.
Yeah.
My store,
it should
get there. It should point to our
sorry. Multiple redirection. I'll fix that. Yeah. That'd
be good.
Sweet. Awesome.
So
let's see what we need to do here.
There are some prerequisites.
Guess maybe we should kind of
Oh, yeah. Well, there there there's one one
one interesting thing actually. There's the the the
we use certain CPU instructions, and we we
we kinda arbitrary decided that if your CPU
is older than ten years, it's like, you
know, buy a new one
or not run Maya store. So there's some
of that.
And it turns out though that the the
the CPUs in in in the in the
cloud are older than you think. But I
in your cluster, I don't think that that's
a problem.
Yeah.
You don't think? I mean, that's not the
most confident answer I've heard there, but we'll
see. Yeah. Yeah. Well, or the CPUs are
not 10 years old there. Right? So No.
No. No. We've we've got pretty recent hardware.
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
Alright. So we got modern CPUs, four gig
of RAM, like that's not gonna be an
issue and we've got huge pages which we've
just enabled. So
let's see. Preparing the cluster.
It's a bit difficult to read. I'll zoom
out a little bit.
Okay. So we did verify huge pages. We've
set oh, see this was all documented. Like
it is just like I should have just
came here first. We aim to please David.
Something about the manual.
I know. I think when I'm going down
some sort of crazy offbeat in path here
and it's like, no. Like, you know, you're
just following the docs like.
So
we have to label the nodes that we
want to run Maya store.
Okay.
Which means
and
oh, I need my node names again.
Hate it when I paste stuff and then
I can't actually see where I am.
I thought the hardest bit would be the
copy and paste. Alright. Let's try again.
Okay.
So
Well, just do the first two for now.
Is that enough for us to get started
or should I run through them all?
Two two would be fine. It will limit
the number of replicas you can have to
to two,
but it would be fine.
I'm almost there now. Three if you want
to push the boat out. This is captivating
TV right here, so I might as well.
Alright,
so
last one.
Okay. Got my labels.
Now we're going to the quick start.
So this is just gonna apply
remote YAML. So this is just creating the
namespace first.
That's right. And this is just for the
control plane of OpenEBS.
It it's data data and control plane. Data
and control. All
of the containers are created in a a
my store namespace.
Then
RBAC,
everybody's favorite.
And the CRDs.
I I call it the cloud native pseudo
actually.
So this is interesting.
So my story is using that under the
hood.
What's going on here?
Yeah. So so as we started to develop
this thing, we we really we realized
that
you may or may not wanna have Maya
store running on all the notes. Right? So,
we needed a way to separate out the
CSI notes from the notes that was actually
running Maya store, and we need a way
to register ourselves against the control plane.
And after,
some trial and error with various approaches and
and and concepts, we said, well, you know,
let's just use a message bus,
because,
you know, that's where these things are are
really good at,
in terms of creating patterns and, you know,
things like that.
And well, then you Google
flight
plus
Kubernetes and we saw Nats and so, okay.
Sold.
Obviously, a little bit more insight went into
that. But NATs is is very lightweight,
and we use it to to register nodes
to the control plane.
And also,
we are working on a fault management subsystem
that
as the IO errors occur within the data
path, one of the things that you cannot
do is is
is determine what you should do based on
that error.
Right? You need a holistic view of the
system as a whole. So we we instead
of handling the error, we we
basically,
dump the error plus some metadata in the
message bus where then a cluster level service
will receive
that message and
keeps track of how many errors and whatnot.
And based on an heuristic, it will determine
then to take a particular replica,
on or offline. That's that's roughly,
the idea,
if that makes sense.
Yeah. I I think so.
I'm concerned
that we have some pending pods.
Let me check why Nets is pending.
If I given us an unhealthy cluster.
I'm
not nervous. You're nervous.
Ready, ready, ready, ready, ready. Alright. Okay. What's
let's take a look at that node list
again, the pod list again.
So it it looks like core DNS is
is not happy.
Yep.
And the Calico cube controller is not happy.
Wonderful.
So I get for trusting get nodes.
Let's see.
That doesn't look right. I'm just gonna delete
that pod and see
if it magically fixes itself.
Computer says no.
The error message is about taints and tolerations.
Right? Do we have to dig into that?
Well, mean, that's not what I was hoping
to do.
I'm gonna edit the node and see. I
don't know why we haven't uninitialized
label.
I'm just going to remove it.
Alright.
Hey. I have no idea what
is going on there. I should probably remove
that from all of our notes, though. This
is the the OpenEBS slash
studying for your your Kubernetes administrator exam
episode.
Yeah. Come and get your CKA learning how
to unfuck your cluster during a demo. Like
okay. I'm just gonna remove the tents.
Oops. Save.
Oh,
just thinking about
if the NVMF
NVMe for fabric kernel module is on
the
machines as well. I just thought about that
actually, which is
Okay. We can take a look at that.
Alright. Let's
I've got at least a good few there
that are running. All those ports are happy.
My cluster is happy. NATS is now happy.
Cool. Problem one resolved.
Problem two is you're worried about the kernel
module. Right?
Well, worried is like
so. Thank you.
Pulled his cable out.
Alright. Well, you fix that. I will just
edit the last node while I'm here.
Where's the last two nodes?
You still there, Jeffrey?
Nope.
Can you hear me?
Sorry. Yeah. I don't know what happened.
Wireless technology.
The
what what operating system are you using?
It is the Ubuntu 20 o four. Okay.
So let me double check.
So if I just run
an LS mod, is there a name of
a module I should be looking for?
It actually, the the quick start,
talks about it,
as well. So the
but I think it was in the prerequisites.
The the quick start will talk about it,
Jeffrey. That that's an oversight at this juncture.
Yeah. So
We have Sorry.
Sorry. Yeah.
So we're looking for n m NVMe dash
t a c p and NVMe t. No.
Just the TCP one. The the the the
other one is not
needed.
Okay. So I can just mod probe that.
Right? Yeah.
So There we go. Easy. Easy easy peasy
lemon squeezy. Okay. Well, that's good.
Cool.
Now there's a command. If I go back
to
Let's go back to the deploy one, right?
So I deployed NATS and then
it wants me to just check NATS it's
happy, which I'm actually I'm okay with. I
think it was running
And now we need to install the CSI
node plug in.
This
is the preflight checklist.
Hey, if I if I all I need
to do is remove some tents from nose
and copy and paste a few more commands.
I mean, think we're doing pretty well.
So we got five. That looks good and
now control
plane.
I
love it when the docs just work. I
mean, it really just makes this a lot
easier.
Kudos on the docs.
I mean, the only thing that's gone wrong
so far is everything I've done upfront. Yeah.
Don't say that too often because Glenn is
on the call and I
yeah. Yeah. No. But that really helps a
lot. Yeah.
Yeah. Just I mean, as someone I mean,
I I'm pretty much a technology magpie. I
just get to play with technology every day
and new stuff and see what happens. And
when the dogs work, it just makes such
a
difference.
I don't wanna give you too much of
an eagle here, Glenn, but so far so
good. It it's okay.
Feel that you're putting me on a pedestal
that I can only fall from. I fall
from grace probably shortly.
Exactly. I just like to build people up
so I can watch them fall. Okay.
So that gave me
oh, I was just a bit too quick.
Right.
Is that us?
That that that is MSN. So it's a
tribute to the the old chat utility that
we all grew up with.
But that stands for Maya storage node, and
and that is,
one of the things that we use NATs
for. So
as Maya store starts up, it starts to
look for the message bus. And then through
the message bus, our control plane gets the
message and then creates this CRD.
And when you describe the CRD, it should
show you some information
about the node
and and stuff like that.
Oh, yeah. It's it's it's a namespace, I
think. So
Yeah. It's a little bit annoying sometimes,
but yeah. Right. So there you go. So
it it it gives us the information of
the gRPC endpoint,
and things like that. So,
this is not,
how to say,
very useful information for for,
a developer necessarily,
but it does show you, like, you know,
all the notes that are there and their
endpoints and and whatnot.
So yeah.
Alright. Sweet. So, I mean,
the next step is is configure managed store.
So just if if we had like a
thirty second summary of where we are right
now, we have
we have OpenEBS deployed with Maya store and
a control plane and data plane and and
and that's it. Right? Yes.
Yes. You you've done a lot of work
but don't have anything yet. That's that's that's
right. If I were to request a PBC
right now, it's just gonna It it won't
work. Yeah. It won't work. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Exactly. Yeah. So so the the next step,
is is to
create
pools as we as we say.
And
we we have stuff in the works actually
and that
facilitates
this to make it a little bit easier,
and there is NDM that also makes it
easier.
But I think for the for the purpose
of of this
exercise,
I think it is probably just easy to
to look on the notes, which is the
disk device that I wanna use and create
a thing like that.
So I think
okay.
I was gonna say, we might get away
with just using SD on everything, but that's
not the case at all.
Yeah. Yeah. So you you can just, you
know, pick one or two notes or whatever.
So I I guess we wanna use the
ones with the NVMe desks or is that
am I wrong there? Does it not matter?
Yeah. It it it it it depends a
little bit on the NVMe drive exactly.
So
if if so if you go back to
the quick start guide Yep. Real quick. So
the we we talk about the schemes. You
go back up a little bit
here. Right? So
this is this is how we connect to
the local storage.
And
the
by default,
we use
AIO because that's common in all kernels. If
it's a more modern kernel, and I think
we just re enable it by default,
we, in in the development branch,
it uses I o u ring. If you
want to go, like, really, really fast, there
is a scheme that's not documented here because
it's very difficult to use still, and that
is PCIe.
Right? So ideally, we would tell the kernel,
let the NVMe device go. We'll handle it
for for you.
But that's rather complicated. So that's not what
the one we're doing? What's that? I I
well, we could, but I would not recommend.
I mean, it it can be a long
exercise because we would need to figure out
the PCIe,
BDF, and and then
yeah.
Alright. So we're gonna go with the NVMe
over fab option?
Is that Well,
I I would just if you go to
the first example tab.
Oh, this one?
One. And just,
so the array of disks,
we only accept one disk still.
Put any disk in there you wanna use,
and Okay. It will just use whatever
So I think I'm just getting confused. Because
I just assumed from this example that I
had to use something that was exposed as
SD. But I I I could still use
slash dev slash m v m e o
one n o one. Is that Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. A block device. Yeah. Whatever. Yeah.
Alright. Let's let's start with the two desks
with the three and a half terabyte NVMe
drive.
Sure.
Okay.
So let me create this file.
Let's not apply it directly to the cluster.
And just so I'm assuming I'm gonna have
to modify this a little bit. Right? So
You're certainly gonna have to change the node
name in the spec section
to the node on which we're creating the
pool.
Okay. So we'll call this pool one dot
yaml.
And
I need to change this to be
value from here,
I believe.
Was there something else you sorry. You said
I had to change there?
Yes. The node the node name. Absolutely.
A pull Is there a way for me
to say,
you know, my cluster is made up of
three different node types. Is there a way
for me to say, identify nodes with this
label and expose this disk?
Not at this time. Good suggestion.
Not not at this time. And, indeed, as
Jeffrey says, we we we do have something
in work to to automate this aspect going
forward. But that's a good suggestion.
I'll be the only one I have. Which
still comes back to, no, I'm sorry, I
gotta be cutting and pasting this
for now.
Alright, so this will be node pool one
and node pool two. I've got this, this.
Is that, does that look okay? I've not
made a mistake there. That looks good. Alright.
Awesome. That looks good. I can apply pull
one.
Okay.
So does that mean I can run
my Azure pulls?
Indeed.
However, you would Namespace. Right? Need to be
in the namespace indeed. And spell it right.
And spell it right. You you can also
type MSP. It's it's like shorter. MSP.
MSP.
Alright. So I have two storage pool, like,
online now.
Yeah.
Is that am I done? Is that it?
Can I go home now?
No. We need to actually create
a PVC.
We'll we'll be needing storage class. Yep. We'll
be needing storage All
that stuff. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. So storage classes we can do. Let's
just continue to add to this file. I'll
make sure all this code is, oh, I
mean, it's mostly copy and paste, I'll still
publish the code to get lab anyway.
So my store
Yeah. We should change that to NVMe
or NVMath, however you wanna phrase it.
Yeah. And the protocol
NVMath. That will need to be yeah. That
will need an f in it.
Yeah. It's
so the the e needs to go?
Yep.
Yep. Alright. And do we do we want
to set the replication factor? Do we want
to have two replicas or are we replicas
or are we happy with one for testing?
Oh.
I mean, now that you've said that, I
I kinda wanna set it to two. It'd
almost be short changed to have one, wouldn't
it?
And I could just apply this. Is there
anything else YAML wise before? Nope. Okay. Let's
just get that applied then.
Alright. So now I have a storage class.
So now I
can run some sort of database that consumes
a storage class. Right? No.
Now you need to create the PVC.
Well, I was assuming we deploy that database
with Helm, and that'll do that for me.
Is that what's on this next page? Oh,
yeah. Well so I I I'm like the
yeah. So I always do it this way
because this this this Helm thing is too
too too fancy for me. But if you
wanna run Helm, I I guess that would
work too. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No. Let's stick
to the docs. Know. Let's not deviate because
in the event it's my mistake when it
goes wrong. And I know I'm already over
to this. Let's
continue to add to this So
we're gonna create a PVC. We'll just call
this super DB.
And
I mean I can just pick any value,
right, for the size. So it's gonna use
to cool. Let me clarify my understanding is
correct here. We have exposed two three and
a half terabyte disks to my store has
created a pool that's replicated.
So I've got seven gig of storage, but
three and a half gig set is available.
Is that correct?
No. So it's it's well,
no.
Yeah.
It it it's an interesting way of thinking
though. So I can certainly see why you
think that way. But the the replication model
is on a per replica.
Right? So you have two
decoupled
three terra three and a half terabyte pools
that can store
whatever.
Right? But when you create a PVC, you
say, I wanna have two replicas, and we
will look for two pools on which to
put the replica.
And then and only then is it, like,
we replicate that data. But the pools themselves
are
a thing on their own.
Yeah. So you you oh, sorry. Yeah. Kiran
Kiran can explain this better. Yeah. So we've
done this with almost all the pools, the
same convention.
So
the storage is not aggregated from different nodes.
The it's kind of stays on that node.
And when we talk about, like, a five
g volume that you create
and you specify two replicas,
it actually saves 10 GB of data. Each
replica has five GB of data when it's
full. Right?
So it's a synchronous duplication of the entire
data on each of the replicas.
Okay. So right now, I mean, my pool
is
is a pool always one desk? What I
mean is, like, if that actual disk dies
at a physical level, then the replication doesn't
help me at all. Is that correct?
Yeah. So if the for the PVCs that
have more replicas, they will survive.
For the PVCs that are on there that
only have one replica,
they're they're gone. But you but that's the
idea that the developer gets what he asks
for, even though it it might not necessarily
always be what he wants.
So we we are
looking into it's like, well, maybe you wanna
have local redundancy as we call it. So
you create a pool, and that pool by
itself is also
redundant.
But that comes at a cost in terms
of, you know, storage.
So
there's traditional Several ways to skin a cat.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. Sorry. So traditional operations wise
then. I mean, when I'm in this kind
of situation, from my experience, I would probably
rate the desks on a hardware level. Is
that still something that would be recommended?
Depends. Depends.
Right? So it's let let me let me
put it this way. Let's say that, I
am a developer and I you're a company
and I work for you and you ask
me to deploy something in Kubernetes
and I see five storage nodes and I
think, oh, let me make sure that I
don't lose that data, I would type replica
as five.
So that means that the system finds nodes
suitable
to put those replicas on.
And then if one of the nodes dies,
I have four. Another one dies, I have
three, and and and so on and so
on. If I say, no. In the cluster,
find a pool. Just put that replica on
that single pool. That pool dies. I lost
my data.
Right? Okay. Now that that's not to say
that we cannot make the pool redundant. We
could.
But
I'm not sure if that that traditional model,
right, would be always the preferred way.
So
yeah. Okay. That makes sense. That that's good.
Okay. So I now have a PVC.
Let's go back to our
I'm not gonna verify the claim. I'm pretty
confident.
Famous last words. I know.
I okay. Okay. Okay. Like, let's run it.
And I called it super d b.
Okay. It worked. Alright. So now
it wants me to actually check the p
b itself.
So
volume.
Alright. That looks good to me.
So
Yeah. There is this is a CRD
and that shows you the
so we we we've created this
almost, like, small very small storage network in
the Kubernetes cluster, it shows you the it
can show you the details of
of how that thing is is is built
up in terms of where are the children
as we call them. So
there's an additional CRD that that does that.
Yeah.
Yeah. It'll be good to do a minus
OEML on that one.
On the MSV?
Yep.
Oh, wow.
So yeah.
So let me see. Let me digest this.
I
Oh, we got replication here. Right.
So so there's the the nexus, and the
nexus has children,
which maybe we should call them replicas.
But anyway
and so the nexus writes to those two
children,
and the children are
replicas
on pool on node two and pool on
node one.
So whoever now mounts the PVC
eventually writes to pool on node two and
pool on node one.
Okay.
It's like a simple mirror mirroring effectively.
Yeah. Jeffrey, again, like, I'm asking some basic
questions here. Why is
one URI
in VMF and the other one is PDF?
Maybe it's Ah, yeah. Yeah. That's a good
question, Kiran. Optimization.
So,
the Nexus itself figured out that, hey. Wait
a minute. One of those two replicas is
actually on the machine that I'm sitting on.
It doesn't make sense to do that over
the DCP socket. Right? So I'll just,
you know, mem copy it. Well, it's actually
a serial copy, but, you know,
bypass the network there.
And future optimizations,
we wanna
give it an affinity such that reads always
go from the local one,
things like that.
We're right in time and bless you. Thank
you. Yeah.
So
let me
I I wanna make sure I've got this
right in my head. So we've created a
master volume
and it's available on both of those nodes.
So my workload has the freedom to migrate
between either of those two nodes if it
wants that PVC.
Is that correct?
No.
No. Close. So the the the the yeah.
I I think
yeah. Next time around, probably should have a
picture.
So the the the nexus
is a NVMe over fabric target.
And
any node in the cluster can connect to
the Nexus
over NVMe over fabric. Also iSCSI, but we're
not going into that. But that's how you
how a node would connect to this PVC.
And then the Nexus then doesn't do anything
other than so it's stateless.
There you go.
But it needs to get this IO out
somewhere,
and it pushes those IOs
out to the children or replicas as it,
is also written down here. So the Nexus
receives the IO from your workload and pushes
that out to those two nodes you see
there, pool node one and pool node two.
That's how the it's like a rate mirror
thing. Right?
Mirror. Okay. So if I if I deploy
a pod that consumes this PVC, it's gonna
be scheduled on one node and always that
node there forward. Is that right?
So the the the workload itself can can
go anywhere because the the way that you
connect to the Nexus is
over a fabric. Right? That's networked.
But likely, the scheduler will put it on
the same note because I think we have
some some rule affinities in there that that
prefer it to go that way or that
way. But, you you can
that's what I meant with that's the reason
why we have the the message bus. Right?
You don't wanna have
the Maya store service run on every node.
Right? So let's say you have five nodes,
only two of them run Maya store and
you mirror them.
And the other three nodes just connect to
the Maya store instances.
Right?
Okay.
We have a question in chat, which will
pop up now.
Oh, boy. So does the Nexus picks the
IO from the app itself?
Or how does that work?
Pick the IO from the app itself.
Not sure.
I was hoping it made sense to you.
If you could give us a a little
bit more detail in the chat, we'll try
and come back to that question. I I
think, Duffy, it's question about does this use
POSIX?
Does it mount?
Or can the app directly communicate to the
Nexus? Oh. Oh, right. Right. Ah, good question.
So we can actually do
well,
maybe I I should stop confusing people, but
we can actually do both.
So if you write an application, you can
use an API to directly write to the
Nexus without anything else. Right?
But the way that is set up now
is that the node that is going to
connect to the Nexus will use the NVMe
over fabric
TCP module that we loaded in the beginning,
right, to connect to the Nexus.
So if if if you if you're familiar
with iSCSI, just just replace iSCSI for NVMe
over fabric. That's it.
Okay. So I think there was something really
cool there. Like, so what you were saying
was my application doesn't have to change. I
can write to a desk and then the
magic happens for me. But I think what
also you alluded to there is I could
make my application
OpenEBS or MyAstro aware and write directly to
the Nexus.
Yeah. Exactly.
Yeah. And in fact, we've done a lot
more work there and don't
get me started, but we we we Jan,
who was on the call, has actually written
a Vert.io driver that allows you and we
actually did this for Go. You have these,
what's it called, interfaces. Right? Read at, write
at, that type of stuff. And if you
implement the interface, you can, you know, use
it the way it was like a file.
And so you could you could use Go
reader and writer to write to a Vert.io
device that would immediately write into
well, it wasn't called MyStore back then, I
must say. But no. So, yes, that is
possible.
And I think that that's, in fact, the
real future because why would you go through
the operating system anyway?
It's like, yeah, because you have a file
system. Well, file systems, why is there a
file system still? They used to be there
too because the caching and da da da,
but it's like, do we really need to?
That's what they mean with DAX DAX file
systems, d a x, direct access file system.
It bypasses the page cache. It's like, sorry,
colonel. You're just slowing us down.
Alright. Cool. That's exciting. Definitely something for another
session I think. Okay.
I I I don't wanna keep us too
far beyond what we actually had scheduled. So
let's assume that in the next twelve minutes
we wanna show off everything that we've done
so far. Are we gonna continue with the
docs, or is there something we should jump
straight to?
I
so
the
if you deploy a file part, then it
would just mount that PVC and run FIO
against it with some very
odd defaults,
like, very small. But, yeah, you could run
that, and then it would,
you know, show you some output in terms
of Do you want to modify that, or
do you want me just to apply it
straight up? No. I I I think it's
fine
for the for the sake of the the
stream. I think
we've changed the name of the claim though,
didn't we, Jeffrey?
Yep.
Oh, yeah. Shoot. The the fire. Yeah. I'm
always expecting it to be called MS volume
claim, and I think we went to super
DB. Did we not?
Sorry.
No. No worries. No worries. So if I
run get deployment
I'm assuming I just created a deployment here.
No. No.
I know it's just a flat pod. Just
I
it's on the Default?
Yep.
Yeah. Okay. Oh, I can't modify it. Okay.
So I'm gonna have to delete the pod,
and then I will need to pull this
down.
That was a c k question. I think
you can modify a pod.
Oh, why can't you modify a pod? Why
not?
The specs immutable. Yeah. Oh, why?
Because you're not supposed to work directly with
pods. You're supposed to use an abstraction.
So this is awesome. I love that you're
using Nexery.dev.
Alright. Isn't it amazing? I'm a huge fan
of Nexery. It's so cool. Yeah. You're familiar
with It's like a dynamic docker registry where
you just tell it whatever commands you want.
Like I could just add w get slash
w get to this. Yeah. Yeah. It's so
good. And it's always the, like, freshly compiled.
If if they commit a new version, it's
you know? Yeah. Anyway. Yep.
Alright. So change that to Super DB. This
runs Yeah. And sleep.
Yeah. And so then what we typically use,
we exec into the container, and then in
the container on file because you wanna see
output. Right? So
Alright. So we deploy file. We should see
that exists this time. Yep. Curating. That's better.
I'll just run a watch on that.
There we go.
Good. I thought I was gonna have to
think of a joke there. So
and we wanna exec in.
I'm in. So let's see.
Oh,
Yeah.
That's alright. I just copied this.
So can someone tell me what file is?
Flexible IO
tester.
It's it's written by, Jens or.
I'm not sure if I pronounced his name
correct.
He's a
guy from Denmark who works at Facebook, and
he is the
the kernel maintainer of the Linux block layer.
So everything block device related,
he's he's kinda, like, responsible for, if you
will.
And, in order to test the stuff, he
thought I need a tool, and there you
go, file.
So it's like the de facto standard to
test block devices, file systems,
whatever.
It has a lot of options.
And so
You can basically simulate any kind of workload
with this sequential random,
small size, big size,
override.
That's a cool part of it. So for
example, like, one of the things that we
did is postgress.
You kind of can replay that and then
convert into a file or test file and
then replay that.
Very flexible too. Flexible is also on the
other. Right?
Alright. It's doing its thing.
Yeah. It's only about one minute?
Yeah.
I think the run time is set to
one minute. Yeah.
But the
what is the one that say? Yeah. It
only creates a small file, obviously. So an
interesting thing to know is, SSDs have a
certain span. I'm not or at least I'm
not sure what the nomenclature is, but
a big CPU vendor calls it spans. Let's
call it that. And if you look at
an NVMe SSD, it has several chips. Right?
And what you wanna do is when you
run a workload, you wanna touch all the
chips because that's how you get the concurrency.
Right? If you write to all chips at
the same time.
And
one issue with SSDs is like so if
you have a small dataset, you're only retouching
a subset of the chips and therefore you
don't have optimal performance.
Right?
If that makes sense. So you're you're not
touching all the chips at the same time.
So there's some of that,
thing to consider when when running,
with,
these things.
But long story short,
that's it.
Excellent.
So
At a scale of one to 10, how
difficult do you think this was
apart from dealing with me, obviously?
This
was painless.
I
mean, I'm pleasantly surprised. I always just think
story is just gonna be one of those
things that you just bang your head off
of it. But I mean even, I know
you said earlier that this is a very
much in development, maybe not quite production yet,
but, know, people can start to use it.
I didn't expect us to be able to
run through the documentation and just get it
to work. Again, the only mistakes or problems
we had were were me. So
yeah. It it yeah. It's it's it's, you
know, it's it's not trivial for sure. And
and and and Kubernetes
by itself is also something that, you know,
is is is not trivial even though it
makes things easier to deploy once you get
a hang of it. It's not trivial. Right?
So
yeah. And
yeah. So, yeah, you can run some stuff
on it and and play with it and
and whatnot. And and
the
we haven't touched upon several other things. Like,
for example,
it's like,
I've actually have a I still need to
blog about it, but we've done some benchmarks
where we where we pushed well over close
to a million IOPS,
on on, NVMe devices. And
for example, it's like how do you define
how many cores you wanna use?
And how do I tell the operating system
to not schedule any workloads on the cores
that I run Maya store on? Because, for
example, if you type l s, you don't
want the kernel to interrupt the Maya store
process. Hey. Where the kernel said, hey, Maya
store stopped. LS gets the run and then
right. So you wanna have these context switches.
You want to
avoid that from happening. And
there are various ways to do that, but
the canonical way is to boot the system
with certain arguments that isolate CPUs and all
stuff like that. So if you really wanna
wanna push the system, there is there is
more work to do, to be fair. So
this is this is like the happy path.
Everything's hunky dory.
But,
you know, if you wanna get to the
optimal performance, there's a little bit more work.
Can you can squeeze the Juicero packet with
your hand and get some of the juice
out, but there's a special machine you can
put the packet in and really get all
the juice out if you want. Yeah. Sounds
like there's a there's a lot of tweaks
and things you can do to get even
more. So excited about it because, you know,
I I work for Equinix Metal. I have
all the bare metal compute that I need
access to ever in the world. And now
I get Don't don't don't make me jealous.
I don't think that's appropriate.
And now I have a storage layer that
is a built with really cool technology like
Rust and doing really cool things. And I
can squeeze the performance out of it to
millions a million IOPS, you know. I mean,
I think that's just terribly exciting and, you
know, that's Yeah.
To tie this back to kind of the
sorry to interject the original presentation that Kieran
introduced with.
To get started, the most important thing is
to have it just work, to have it
install and just
be there and up and running. And over
time,
as applications grow, as your your business or
your project grows, that scale tends to favor
customization,
I I like to say. So there's a
lot of more knobs and a lot more
buttons you wanna turn and press.
And
our solutions, OpenEBS
and Myasore, are kind of built with that
in mind.
We want it to be easy to set
up and get going, but we also wanna
give you those knobs and buttons for when
you're ready to scale and do that extra
stuff to really get going. Well, is there
okay. So before we we wrap this up,
is there anything anyone here wants to show
before
we conclude today's session? Is there anything that
we haven't covered that we think is important
to
I'm thinking. Well, I
mean, yeah, I would I mean, we could
go through some some logs and and see
some stuff on how it you know?
But I think this is pretty much it.
We try to keep it very, very simple
at the beginning and then
get the foundation right and then start to
come up with some more sophisticated
stuff.
Yeah. Awesome.
I think
this was like a great introduction and we
go hands on and we and we showed
how it works. I mean, I'm definitely gonna
speak to you all afterwards and see if
we can line up another session where we
we dive into all those other concerns OpenEBS
tries to bring, snapshots and backups and really
try and you know understand the full landscape
of storage on Kubernetes. But I think for
today, this was fantastic. I just wanna say
thank you to all of you for joining
me.
Like I said, that's the first time I've
had this many people on this stream and
it was an absolute pleasure. Thank you.
Well, thank you. For having us. Thanks. Alright.
Well, you all Yeah.
You all have a great day, and I
will speak to you all soon. Thank you.
Bye bye. Thank you.